uh we actually met
at um in 2014
uh at a at a bar called place to beach
deep in coney island brooklyn like real
like not gentrified new york like real
new york like she's puerto rican i was
italian it was like west side story
stuff and we met and um they were
singing they were singing dude it was a
full musical and and and we met and then
we went out on a date uh a couple of
weeks later and what was your line to
her did she know you did she was she
recognized you from tv no no no no um
and and i said to her that um i walked
up to her and because she's latina and
she was dancing and i was like i'm a
salsa instructor and she was like
do a move and i was like i have a i have
a kidney issue and she said you have a
kidney issue and i fired yeah
and she started laughing and she was
like you're an idiot and i was like see
and see
which is uh spanish yes yes in spanish
yes and then she told and then and then
and then it's you know i whatever struck
out and then before i left i was like i
just really like i'd love to like take
you out on a date and she was like um
she was like uh yeah no i'm with
somebody and i was like okay great so i
just like you know left and i was like
ruined
girl my dreams gone what can you do and
then she sent me a message like a week
later because we had taken pictures we
were taking pictures in there and
hashtagging place to beach that was the
name of the bar so she looked up the
hashtag placed the beach it was just on
it because her friend owned it and saw
me and was like oh whatever i guess
things didn't work out with that other
guy and she messaged me and then we went
out on a date a week later uh and on the
second date
we had sex i had fun
and i splooched because she had the
lemons and the papercuts and she wasn't
wearing a poncho and she got pregnant
immediately with my daughter delilah
second date oh wait the second date that
we ever had in our so
my daughter when she was born it was an
accident yeah a hundred percent yeah
accidentally oh it's spanish
[Music]
that's not your billboard on the back of
every bus in town is it
what was it in l.a it says accidente on
the back of every bus
you have to i don't know if it's a new
york thing i don't know if they have it
in any other city but if you drive
around here you look next time you see a
public transit bus there's always
i had no idea it was about you [ __ ]
your wife on the second date yes that's
and you advertised it yes so wait she
got pregnant how did you find out that
she got pregnant so actually she told we
we then you know had sex and we were
having fun or whatever and then we
didn't you know just no condom it was
all casual no well i had it on for the
for like two or three pumps and i was
like i can't do this and then i took it
off and she was okay with that it was
okay with that we were drinking you know
it was passionate she were having sex
she was like papi i was like okay no but
weren't you gonna but why didn't you
pull out um
that's a good question what that's a
good question oh no why didn't you what
yeah look what happened i'm sitting
beside it because i wanted to do a
podcast i said to my wife
i want to do a podcast in 37 years and i
don't want to do it alone
oh my god there you go and there's
jackie
you know you know what i feel terrible i
know i'm sorry even uh caroline and
everybody back there is just like
cringing yes well it's funny because i
went into this podcast saying my
mother's such a huge howie mandel fan
and i was like let's call her
you want to call her yeah wait i want to
know what you were saying okay so but i
i okay um so i said um
i said uh you know to her you know we
kind of were talking not talking like
just casual whatever we were both single
and um your mother and you my mother my
mother is single fyi um i'm confused now
who are we talking about do you like
women with gerd gastroesophageal reflux
disease oh my god is that i i figure oh
my god we have it baby we have gerd a
measure paul i think i just splooged a
little there you go hear that mom
um so she's gonna kill me for this well
so is my daughter killing me for sitting
beside me through this what can you do
so
so
so she so uh you know we're we're like
kind of both single she had a child she
had a three-year-old son um from the
date of the guy that when she was
dancing exactly yeah then another guy
three years ago yeah and did that and
then so we
it was september 11th okay september 11
2014. oh yes yeah yeah yeah
what do i do december 11th 2014 and i
was in tampa at uh side splitters comedy
club shout out science splitters and um
and and you just had more shout outs
shout out go ahead yeah shout out side
splitters and uh where the owner the
previous owner of the club was she was i
remember i got a text from from jasmine
while the owner of the club was telling
me about how the night before you had
punched a woman in the face and wanted
to show me on the uh on the security
footage i was like i'll pass thank you i
was like yeah i just knocked her out
who's jasmine
huh who's jasmine jasmine is my is my uh
girlfriend we're actually not married my
girlfriend the mother of your children
of my children yeah mom
spanish yes okay i love that because
this uh this is not a closed caption
podcast but it doesn't have to be
well with you here it is yeah but the
point is so jasmine
who got punched in the face uh some
woman in the parking lot of side
splitters in tampa but the owner of the
comedy club was telling me that he
punched a woman the night before and was
proud of it and you said well i [ __ ] a
woman a week before oh yeah i'm proud of
it what did you do any video of that
wait i'm so confused so story started
with you telling us how you found out
that she was pregnant yeah i think this
is the story telling us about how
excited your mom was that you're coming
on
and now we're talking about someone
getting punched in the face que paso
yeah
spanish
yeah yeah i i well i because that my
podcast is called christy chaos where we
go all over the place so let me try to
just get in there so like i did where
are we going in july where we're going
shut up so he can just dad shut up
whoa
oh my god let him finish
so
sorry is this one i should just be happy
i didn't pull out
so
we so she you know
she
she
she texts me and she goes um jasmine she
goes i'm i'm gonna come to tampa uh
tonight i it was you know she was like
i'm going to come to tampa tomorrow i
meant and i was like oh awesome like you
know come like have fun i could buy the
beach we'll hang out i felt like it was
just going to be like fun you know hook
up whatever blah blah blah blah i was
like this is great we'll have fun
you know great and then she comes gets
to tampa and she's doing shots just she
had shots i come off the stage and she's
like let's have shots lined up i was
like well this girl's ready to party
fine fun whatever both single have fun
so we go she's like drinking
and talking and we go back to the room
and she's like uh she said i'm so
[ __ ] drunk right now i was like good
good for you i was like let's get it on
and she was like that's that's this i
like the way you do it the way you say
it yeah women must just oh they loved it
yeah let's get it yeah i had my nipples
were fine i don't think i've ever heard
besides barry white you're the second
person yeah i've ever heard say that
yeah right that's right yeah oh it was
marvin gaye it was marvin gaye who's
who's saying let's get it on marvin gaye
marvin gaye marvin gaye and now you
chris chrissy gay
that's who i am or gay chrissy is what
they call me in the neighborhood you're
gay chrissy g-a-y-e though because i'm a
marvin gaye fan
i'm kidding so okay yeah i'm chrissy
accidentae so
so
so she tells me she goes to the bathroom
and i thought i thought she was going to
come out butt ass naked right right but
instead she comes out fully clothed with
a pregnancy test that's positive and
she's like
this is why i'm here uh she was like you
know i have a son already i'm just here
to i just wanted to tell you that
obviously i'm pregnant um but you know
i can't possibly do this with you so i
just want you to help me take care of
this and be there for me and that's all
i want that's why i'm here and you know
i don't think we should speak anymore
after this and um but she didn't want to
keep the baby no not at that point she
was like no i could tell the way she
drank before
she was like i don't wanna you know she
was like let's go jet skiing let's just
forget about this i'm pregnant let's go
jets let's go jet ski and drink let's do
heroin whatever and i was like okay uh
and then i was like so you don't wanna
do this and she was like do you wanna do
this you barely even know me and i have
another child and you're a comedian and
and i was like um
and it was like this moment that i had
where i was like i don't know i i was 30
years old at the time i had a
okay career i had my education
you know was raised catholic sorry
and were you apologizing to jews
so he looked at if you're not if you're
just listening he looked at my me
the big bald jew and my jewish daughter
and when i'm catholic i apologize all
right well cause i you know i have
catholics but shouldn't we be
apologizing apparently we killed jesus
you did kill our guy sorry but what can
you do i don't know but he was jewish he
was jewish yeah okay but you know yeah
well we'll see i i don't know i don't
know if he's married to a catholic guy
oh wow there you go how do you like it
it's fine it's good yeah right so we're
really not that fun
um so she so she's i had this moment and
she said i say to her i was like i know
this is crazy i know we don't know each
other i know
i'm responsible for my action we're both
responsible for our actions obviously
i'm completely okay your body your
choice whatever you want to do i'll pay
for it i'll support you i'll be there in
any way you need me i've never been in
this situation before so just tell me
what to do and i will do that if that's
what you want but
i will say that i will also gladly be
the father of this baby and i promise
you that i will you know
like
we don't know each other so i was like i
don't know how if we're gonna last i
don't know but i promise you that i will
be the father of this baby and it will
be my whole life i promise you and i
guess you could just feel that i was
being i meant that i can feel it yeah
well put a poncho on
so
so she said if i i i can then i'll keep
it if that's what you mean then i'll
keep it and you went fine
and then you know what it's the best
decision i ever made because we had our
we have our baby and now we have another
we have our our older daughter and we
have a baby daughter i have my stepson i
have a whole life a whole puerto rican
life
[Music]